Today, I'm really excited to
be joined by my close friend
and colleague Joshua Angrist,
a professor of economics also
at MIT, and newly minted Nobel
Prize winner for his work
on natural experiments
in economics,
and by our colleague
Clémence Idoux,
a researcher at Blueprint
Labs and an MIT PhD graduate.
Today's talk will be
pretty wide ranging.
But we'll focus mainly on
Blueprint Labs research
into admissions policies
in public schools
and their impacts on integration
and student achievement.
I'll introduce Josh and Clémence
and get into our discussion
in just a moment.
But first, let me make a
few housekeeping notes.
I'll ask Josh and Clémence each
to tell us a little bit about
themselves and their work.
And then, we'll get into a
discussion about their research
and its implications,
what they've learned,
recommendations for
educators, and so on.
For the last 15
minutes or so, we'll
open it up to audience
Q&A. At any time,
please feel free to put
questions for our panelists
into the chat.
Our moderators today,
Janine and Catherine,
will be collecting
all of the questions
for us to go through
during the Q&A.
If you'd like to go on camera
and ask your question directly,
please use the Raise
Hand function on Zoom,
and a moderator will promote
you to panelists during the Q&A.
And if you have any questions
about any of this, please
put them in the chat, and
the moderators will help you.
So without further
ado, let's get started.
Josh, I'm going
to start with you.
Josh Angrist is the Ford
Professor of Economics at MIT,
a co-founder and director
of MIT'S Blueprint Labs,
and a research associate
at the National
Bureau of Economic Research.
Josh, can you tell us
a bit about your work?
I'd love to, Parag.
Thanks so much for that very
flattering introduction.
It's been an unusually exciting
semester for us at the lab.
Usually, we have a lot
of excitement anyway.
This has been extra
special this fall.
Of course, I'm
thrilled and humbled
to have been recognized
with a Nobel Prize
and to share the Prize
with my thesis advisor--
one of my thesis
advisors, Dave Card,
and my long-time
collaborator Guido Imbens.
I have a couple of fun pics
to share with our audience--
let me see if I can
get that to work--
from the Nobel experience.
Let's see if that'll
come up on my iPad.
And so, what we
do in the lab is,
we estimate causal effects
of things related to schools.
So I think of that as
illuminating the path for cause
to effect.
And that's what the Prize
recognizes-- that kind of work.
So all of us at
Blueprint Labs, we
couldn't be more
pleased by this.
And it really is a
group effort at the lab.
It's been a little disruptive.
So that's what I came home
to early on October 11th--
photographers in my driveway.
I'm holding my granddaughter.
And that's my wife Mira there.
And it's more or less
been like that ever since.
I'm looking forward
to going back to work,
having a little coffee, and
getting up to a quieter day.
But it is inspiring
to get the Prize.
There's an inspiring quote in
Steven Pinker's latest book,
which I think reflects the way I
feel about the work that we do.
I was surprised to
see this in the book.
And it means that we're sort
of really getting our tools out
there.
When a data scientist finds
a regression discontinuity
or an instrumental variable,
it's a really good day.
And I'm hoping that I've
made those days better
for some people with the
work that I do at Blueprint.
I'm very lucky to have such
fine collaborators at the lab,
like Parag and our
talented student Clémence.
We've been working as a team
for over a decade on questions
related to schools.
We work on school assignment--
how kids choose and are
offered opportunities
to attend different schools.
And we work on
school effectiveness,
which we typically
measure by the learning
gains or the effects
of school attendance
on how likely students are
to eventually go to college.
These sound like fairly
quotidian matters.
But as you'll soon see in
Clémence's presentation--
and she's really the
star of the show today--
this is the heart of
the matter for one
of the most controversial
and important questions
in American public life.
And that's the question
of integration--
racial integration in schools,
and what sort of policies
facilitate integration, and what
sort of policies inhibit it.
And closely related to
that is the question
of school effectiveness--
whether opportunities
to attend different schools
indeed promote learning
and lead to better outcomes.
School quality for many people
is really life-changing.
And I like to make this point
by mentioning a paper that David
Card-- who's one of
the Prize winners--
the Nobel that I share--
wrote with our late friend
Alan Krueger in the early '90s.
They showed that improvements
in school quality
really explains a
substantial fraction
of the gains in earnings
of Black men in the 1960s
and '70s.
And there was great progress
in terms of the racial earnings
gap in those decades--
not complete convergence
by any means.
We have a long way to go--
but progress nonetheless.
And a lot of that progress is
explained by increasing school
quality and increases in
the quality of the schools
that Black men attend.
We focus on men typically in
research from that period,
because female labor
force participation
rates were relatively low.
In any case, the topic
today is certainly
interesting, and exciting,
and relevant to current policy
debates.
Parag, Clémence, and I
have uncovered all sorts
of interesting findings
related to the effects of going
to schools of different types in
Boston, Chicago, and New York.
And as part of her thesis work,
Clémence has taken a deep dive
into the consequences of an
unprecedented change in New
York City assignment policies in
an effort to reduce segregation
in two of the city's
highest income areas.
They're called districts,
because New York is so big.
Even smaller parts of New York
are called school districts.
In any case, I'll hand off now
to Clémence and let her tell
this remarkable story.
Great, Josh.
Thank you so much.
Clémence, the show is yours.
Thank you for the introduction.
Let me share some slides that
I can show you some pictures
as well--
that won't be as funny as
Joshua here, I'm afraid.
But that's hard to beat.
And so, like as I
think, Josh said,
I received my PhD
from MIT this year.
And now, I'm a
post-doctoral fellow
at MIT Department of
Economics and Blueprint Labs.
And so during my PhD,
I focused my research
on understanding what are
the consequences of school
assignment rules on student
achievement and school
diversity.
So what I mean is
whether you can
design a system of
school admission
that can increase school
diversity or increase test
scores.
Today, I will focus on
my work in New York City.
So I've been
studying the past two
years, the consequences of New
York City integration policies.
And as the starting
point from this project
was the observation that
American school districts are
still very much segregated
although more than almost
70 years have elapsed since
Brown v Board of Education,
which is, as you may know,
the Supreme Court ruling that
ordered all school districts
across the US to desegregate.
So to give you a number,
roughly 17% of American schools
today enroll a student body
that is approximately 75% Black
or Hispanic students.
These are a lot of discrepancy
on the student body
of different schools in the US.
And this has driven a
lot of media attention.
And when the public debate
talks about this question,
it often focuses on the question
of racial differences in access
to selective enrollment schools.
So selective
enrollment schools are
schools that select students
based on past achievement
or other characteristics.
I'd like to cite some.
For instance, a free
exam school in Boston.
I typically selected
enrollment schools
because they select people
based on the result at an exam.
During the COVID-19
pandemic, testing
was interrupted in
many cities in the US.
And as a result, there
was an increased interest
in screened school access.
And this is reflected
by some articles I've
pulled over in the screen here.
And for instance, in Virginia,
the first high school board
decided to eliminate
admission test
to its very selective and
prestigious high schools--
the Thomas Jefferson
High School-- last year.
In Boston, so just on the other
side of the river from here,
BPS have enacted two
successive admissions reforms
in the past two years.
And this admission
reform targeted
the city free exam schools.
So this free school in
Boston that selects student
based on an exam.
Those are upper middle
school and high school.
They select student
from seventh grade on.
And so, as a city, the
two successive rounds
of admissions reform
was slightly different.
But basically, the idea was to
give some preferential access
to this very prestigious
school to students from lower--
from disadvantaged backgrounds.
The city created some system
of priority for these students
so that they would get
better access to these very
prestigious schools.
In New York City, finally, last
year the New York City school
board decided to suspend
academic screen for admission
at its middle school for a year.
And the suspension has been
extended for another year
this year, since the
city didn't have any test
score to base admission on.
So there has been this
very temporary suspension
of screening in middle schools.
So just to say, there has
been this increased interest
in this issue of whether
these selective admissions
policies are contributing
to segregation
in American schools.
New York City is quite
an interesting place
to study this question.
Because first, it's the
larger school districts
in the United States.
So the district,
as you may know,
enroll roughly one million
of students every year.
And that's approximately
0.3% of the US population.
The district is also
deemed one of the most
segregated in the country.
So to give you a number, 50%
of schools in New York City
enroll more than 90% of
Black and Hispanic students
that are also eligible for
free and reduced price lunch.
That is a vast disparity
of the student population
enrollment across schools.
New York City is
also interesting,
because it's a city in
which screen schools are
very prevalent.
So roughly one third
of New York City middle
and high school screen students
on past academic performance
in 2018.
So prior to the suspension
of academic screening,
one third of middle
schools in New York City
were admitting students based
on their past performance.
So you would get your
admission at a school
based on whether you did
well in elementary school.
So in response to
this challenge,
in 2019, two New York
City school district--
so as Josh said, New
York City is very big.
And so, it's divided in
32 local school districts
that you can see
in this picture.
And two of them--
so the Upper West Side District,
which is in blue up there,
and the Northwest
Brooklyn District,
which is orange down here--
so it's in the Northwest
of Brooklyn--
decided to adopt diversity
management plans.
So the idea behind
these plans were
to try to integrate the
middle school in these two
districts of the city, which
is as Josh pointed out,
the wealthiest district in the
city, and also the two district
in which segregation
was very prevalent.
And so, this district
decided to reduce
the role of academic
screens in admissions
and in order to try to
increase integration
at the district schools.
So then, in my research, what
I have to try to understand
is whether this
reform worked out.
So whether actually
they achieved their aim
and what were the
consequences in terms
of enrollment and application
behavior from [INAUDIBLE]..
Whether this reform
had other consequences
on how people choose
the school they
apply to and which school
they decide to enroll in.
So I want to present three key
findings from this research.
Before diving into
the first finding,
I just wanted to give
you some more background
information about what exactly
these two district did.
So these district-- so they
both enacted reform 2019.
And the reform were
slightly different.
So in Upper West Side,
what the district did
was, that they decided to
keep academic screening.
So students would
still be screened
based on their past test
scores when they were
applying for middle school.
But they set aside 25% of
seats in each middle school
for students that are eligible
for a reduced price lunch
and have low test scores.
So if you were a student
in the Upper West Side,
and you had a test score
below a certain threshold,
and you were also eligible for
free or reduced price lunch,
then you would get a priority
for this 25% of seats.
So the idea was to expand
the access to the school
to students who are low
income and low achieving.
In Northwest Brooklyn, the
reform was a bit more radical.
So the idea was, the
district decided actually
to eliminate all
academic screen.
So what that means, is that
middle school would only
admit student based on
their lottery numbers.
So in New York City
every year, students
are assigned lottery
number, and that determines
in part their admission.
And so, in Northwest Brooklyn,
after the reform in 2019,
students would be admitted
only based on that number
and not based on their
past academic performance.
The district also set
aside 52% of seats
for students who are
low-income English language
learners or homeless.
So which means that students
that would qualify for these C
priority would be
put first on the list
when the school were
filling their seats.
That means, they would
get an extra priority
for this 52% of seats.
And so, the first thing
I found in my research
is that this policy that
reduced the role played
by academic screens decreased
racial inequality in school
segregation to some extent.
And so, that's what
I'm showing you here.
So it is maybe a
complicated graph.
There, I'm displaying you the
evolution of school segregation
for Black districts.
In blue, you can see the
evolution of school segregation
for Upper West Side, in
orange for Northwest Brooklyn,
and in gray for other New
York City school districts.
The left panel is
school segregation
for low-income students.
So that correspond to measure
of school economic school
segregation.
While the right panel
is school segregation
for Black and Hispanic students.
So that corresponds to
measure of racial segregation.
As you may see,
for the gray line,
is flat, which
means that there was
no change in school segregation
in other district in the city.
Which makes sense, because
there was no change in policy.
Whereas we can see
a decrease in school
segregation for
Northwest Brooklyn
after the enactment
of the reforms.
So school segregation
were roughly at 15%,
and it dropped around
10 percentage points
after the reform.
For Upper West Side, the
picture is less clear.
The decrease is less marked.
And this is consistent with the
fact that the plan they adopted
was a bit less radical.
As you can see as well,
the drop in segregation
is more marked for
low income students
than for Black and
Hispanic students.
So that means that
there was a larger
decrease in economic
school segregation
than racial specific.
The second key
finding of my research
was that, actually, families
reacted to this reform.
And they reacted by
changing their application
and enrollment behaviors.
So what I mean by that is
that, when finally decided
where to enroll, what I found
is that after the reform,
some group of students
were more likely to enroll
in a school outside the
traditional public school
system.
So they were more likely not
to enroll in the New York City
public school but to
enroll either in a charter
or in a private school.
And the group of
students that were
more likely to exit the
public school system
was white and higher
income students.
Specifically, they were
6% to 8% more likely
to enroll in a school that was
outside the traditional public
school system.
And to give you an
idea, the baseline rate
of enrollment outside
the public school system
is of 10% in Upper West
Side and 17% in [INAUDIBLE]..
So this increasing
exits is substantial.
On the other hand,
Black, Hispanic, Asian,
and lower-income
students were unaffected.
So they enrolled the same
rate in public school
after the reform than before.
Then, I tried to investigate
why white and higher income
students were more
likely to exit.
And what I found is
that family seems
to be responding to the
fact that after the reform,
children were assigned to school
with lower achieving peers
on average.
So it seems to be the
case that families
are leaving the district
in response to the fact
that they were assigned to a
school in which their peers--
the classmate of their kid would
have had lower test scores.
On the application
side, what I found
is that there was also
a change in the type
of school families applied to.
So after these reforms finally
started applying to more
schools, and students
that were low-achieving--
so that had lower grades
in elementary schools--
decided to apply to more
competitive schools.
And this application
response tended
to increase the effectiveness
of the [INAUDIBLE]..
Because students that
were lower-achieving
and they're often also
lower-income, ended up
applying to school
that were enrolling
more higher-income students.
Finally, as a last step of my
analysis, what I tried to do
is to understand what would
happen if the city was
to enact a similar reform.
And so, I basically
perform a simulation
of what would a school
segregation look
like in New York City if
the city was to change
its admissions system.
That's why I'm showing
you in these bar charts.
In these bar charts, you
have the level of segregation
in purple and under the
actual admission regime.
Then in green, I have a
counterfactual admission regime
in which the city is not using
academic achievement to screen
students anymore.
And finally, in red, you have a
regime in which both as a city
is not using either academic
screens or geographic screens.
What I mean by
geographic screens
is screening based on where
does this student live.
In New York City, you
may get some priority
because you live
close to a school.
And so, if the city was also
to drop this kind of priority,
you would get to the red bar.
So from this
picture, what you can
see is that the
drop in segregation
is much larger when the
city is also dropping
geographic screens,
which tend to entail
that geographic screen
are a bigger driver
of segregation than
academic screens.
But you can also see that these
still residual segregation
even when the city is
not admitting students
based on either academic
or geographic screens.
And this residual
segregation is clearly
due to family preferences
and residential segregation.
So the fact that the city
is segregated by people
from different race and
different socioeconomic
background live in
different neighborhoods.
And they tend to send your
kids to different school
and also to apply to
different schools.
So even if the city were
not to use any admission
criteria to admit
students to the schools,
you would still have this
remaining segregation.
So taking stock, I
think that's what
I learned from this project
is that admission reform has
the potential for curbing
segregation in New York City
schools.
And why I'm saying that
is because roughly 50%
of school segregation
is accounted
by academic and geographic
admission screens.
Geographic screens
appear, actually,
to be more important
than academic screens.
So if the city was willing
to lower segregation more,
according to my
simulation, it would
be more effective to
drop geographic screens.
Nonetheless, one have
to take into account
that it appears that white and
high-income applicants could
exit the traditional public
school district in response
to such reform.
So it's unclear to
what extent they would.
But it seemed to be the case
that white and high-income
applicants tend to exit the
public school district when
there is an admission
reform that [INAUDIBLE]
importance of screening.
I think that these
are interesting if you
put into the context that
New York City is actually
currently considering
further education reforms.
So in particular,
as the city has
been discussing the removal
of geographic screens
in high schools
and the phase out
of gifted and talented
programs in elementary schools.
And so, I mean, in
light of my analysis,
it would be curious to see
whether these policies are
implemented and how they
fare if they are implemented.
And I think that's
all I had to say.
I'm going to give
it back to Parag.
Terrific, Clémence.
Thank you so much.
That's a really fascinating
and topical work.
What I want to do now is open
it up to a conversation with you
and also with Josh before
opening it more generally
to the broader audience.
And Clémence, let me start
off just by asking a couple
of questions about your work.
And you mentioned New York City
is the nation's largest school
district.
And a lot of the country
has been paying attention
to the efforts to try to
integrate the Upper West
Side and Northwest Brooklyn.
What I wanted to
ask you about is
if you could speak on
what the reaction has
been from your contacts in
New York City to your results.
And more generally,
if you could say
a bit more about
your relationship
with the folks at the
Department of Education,
and what it's been
like to do research
that is so topical and
sometimes emotionally charged.
Yeah.
So this research
was mostly possible
because of the collaboration
of the New York City Office
of Enrollment and Research.
And I think it was a
very interesting part
of the work, actually,
this collaboration.
Because so, they bring more
a policy-oriented approach
to the work.
And they know better what
is playing on the ground.
What are policymakers' worries,
what families are saying
in reaction to this policy.
And so, it was great
very good interaction
to orient the research
and to understand
what might be important
and what might be feasible.
So in general, I think that
these kind of policymaker
and academic interaction are
very relevant for research.
And it could give you
a different perspective
from your work that what you
would have just by looking
at your result by yourself.
And it was very enriching for
me to collaborate with the New
York City School District and
get their feedback on my work.
And it was very much--
we had a lot of discussion
when I was developing the work.
And I could take into
account their reaction
to my early findings.
So that was quite interesting.
That's great.
It seems like that partnership
has been quite fruitful.
And let me turn to
another question, which
is maybe going to ask you to
speculate a little bit more.
So you mentioned some of the
new reforms that were proposed.
And we've just had an
election in New York City,
where there's a new mayor.
And New York City is a
school district where
the mayor has a lot of control.
It doesn't have an
elected school board
unlike many other cities.
What are the big issues in New
York City schools these days?
And if you could
whisper into the ear
of the mayor and the
new superintendent
about the coming issues,
what would you tell them
about what they
should focus on based
on your research and your
knowledge on this topic?
That's a great
question. (LAUGHS)
So I think, there has been a lot
of-- so I think that actually,
like you mentioned, that the
mayor has a lot of power.
So there's also a lot of
uncertainty of what's going on.
And I think that something
I've seen a lot in my work
is that parental
understanding of the system
is somewhat heated sometimes.
So I think that a
very basic thing that
would be useful in
New York City is
to have a better
communication between parents
and the administration.
So actually, the
reform in district 15
was a great example of that,
in which the reform went
relatively smoothly, even
though it was actually
dropping all academic
screens because there was
a lot of community involvement.
And so, that's something
that maybe would be useful.
Because we've been
talking a lot about all
the possible admission
reform that could happen.
And every time, it seems
like there's a backlash.
And there's not
much understanding
of what's going to happen next.
So I think that that
would be an interesting--
in terms of admission
policies, it
would be great and
quite important to get
the communication clear.
Also because it seems
to be that there's
some barriers to information
in New York City.
So there was a study
a couple of years
ago that showed that students
didn't really understand
what their options were.
And so, that could
be an easier step
to take, than overhauls in the
whole admissions system just
to reduce barrier
of information.
Terrific.
Great.
Let me see if we can try to
get Josh also to weigh in
on our next question here.
And this is a
question a bit more
about what economists bring to
debates about education policy.
So much of the
conversation about efforts
to integrate and
desegregate schools
are based on strong moral and
ethical arguments, or arguments
that date at least to the
Brown versus Board of Education
decision in the 1950s.
And Brown casts a
very long shadow
on even debates in
the current era.
I'm curious, what
does an economist--
someone who works with numbers--
really have to say about these
moral and ethical issues?
How does an economist
approach questions
about the effects
of segregation?
Josh, maybe you
want to go first.
And then, we'll
hand it to Clémence?
Sure.
Well, I don't know
if I could speak
for all economists, of course.
But speaking for
myself, and I think
this is the ethos
in the lab, we would
like to see schools integrated.
But we approach questions
related to segregation,
and school assignment,
and school effectiveness
dispassionately--
I think that's our
primary contribution.
We're interested in the
consequences of, for example,
descreening.
Descreening is well-intentioned,
but that doesn't
mean that it works out well.
We need to consider the
consequences of that.
Did that actually
increase access?
And also, we need to
confront possibilities
like white flight.
And Clémence's study addresses
these issues beautifully.
And she approaches it without
any preconceived notions.
And the facts are there for
policymakers to consider.
Of course, that's not the only
consideration that's relevant.
But I think it's
essential to know
what the actual consequences
of an intervention
like descreening are.
And our role is to provide that
kind of objective information.
And then, it's up
to decision-makers
how they use it.
But we can also help
guide that discussion.
For example, simulations of the
kind that Clémence does can be
used to explore consequences of
things that have not yet been
tried.
So for example,
descreening citywide.
There our results
are more speculative.
But again, we approach
these problems and questions
as scientists, when we
answer the question, what
are the consequences
of descreening.
Then there's a separate
follow-on step,
which is how that
information is used.
Thank you, Josh.
Clémence, maybe I could ask
you just to add a couple
of thoughts on how economists
have looked at the effects
of segregation--
either in New York or elsewhere.
So I think that something
that I haven't touched on
and that is interesting is
whether that effect also--
like as Josh points
out, in our lab,
we have very interesting
effect on test scores,
and maybe also on other measure
of development of freedom.
And this is not something that
is very excellent evidence as
of now.
So that's something that
would be interesting to see
more work on in the future.
So there are some evidence that
when desegregation happened
in the '70s, and '80s,
that was a '60s, '70s,
that was beneficial
to Black students that
had an increase in test scores.
Nonetheless, it's hard to know
whether it was because increase
in funding or just the
exposure to more diverse peers.
So that is something that
clearly an economist would
be interesting in studying.
There are barriers, is not
an easy question to tackle.
And this study would have been
a good one, but [INAUDIBLE]..
So there were some limits here.
But clearly, that's
something which economists
would weigh in, which is
more the dimension of benefit
from integration.
And there's no very
striking evidence
for that in a more recent year.
So there are some evidence
from historical desegregation,
in fact, but not from these
more contemporary efforts.
Terrific.
Great.
Now, let's maybe zoom out a
little bit from New York City.
It is the Big Apple, but there
are other cities, Clémence,
that you've studied and
Josh has also studied.
Maybe, Clémence, you could
tell us a little bit about some
of the research you've done
with Boston Public Schools--
the questions you've
looked at, the approaches,
and what you've been finding.
Yes.
That's, I feel, related.
In the sense that so in Boston,
I study exam school admission
policies.
And what I was
interested in there is
was to understand whether
you could actually
increase test score by changing
the admission policies.
So I was not so much
focusing on diversity,
but more trying to
understand could you
design a system in which you
raise test score in the city
by just changing who gets
admitted to an exam school.
And what I found is actually
that contrary to what one would
believe, it's not like the
characteristic of the student
that matters much.
So it's not because the student
is a high-achieving student
that he would benefit
more from an exam score.
It's not also,
minority students don't
appear to be benefiting more
from attending an exam school.
What seems to matter
more is which school
is their alternative school.
So which school would have
been the outside option
of these students
if they had not been
admitted to an exam school.
And so, I found that actually
if you were to design system,
you should give
priority to students
that live in neighborhood
in which the neighborhood
school is of worse quality,
you get a higher test score
for the city.
What is interesting is that a
neighborhood in which schools
are not particularly
good are not
necessarily
neighborhood in which
a lot of low-income and minority
students live in Boston.
So this is not necessarily
related to the test
score of the student either.
So you need to be--
to try to actually measure
what the school is providing
to the kid, and not
just look at what
are the characteristics
of the kids.
If you want to
design such a system,
you need to actually
understand what
is the value add of
the school, which
is something us economists
care a lot about, which
is what the school add to a
[INAUDIBLE] test score, and not
only what is the kid test
score at the end of the school.
Because otherwise,
you might just
be selecting those kids that
would have had very high test
score anyway.
So what I find in this
other line of research
is that you could actually try
to design a system in which you
target students that have
low value-added alternative.
And that's more efficient.
So that's a different
perspective on admission
that is not so much
focused on diversity,
but more on how school systems
can raise test score by just
changing very more
administrative rules
of admission.
Terrific.
And Clémence, that
work in Boston--
Boston has actually made
some serious changes,
you mentioned in your
slides-- to their admissions
policy for these exam schools,
taking into account aspects
of where kids live.
Is that right?
Is that on the table
still in the city?
Yes.
Terrific.
Josh, maybe I'll turn to you.
So the lab that you co-direct
works in New York and Boston.
Could you tell us a bit
more about education topics
that folks at the lab have
addressed-- your own work maybe
in other cities or
in other settings?
Sure.
So the lab that we
share broadly covers
two sorts of education topics.
We have our K
through 12 division.
And that looks at
public education
in large urban districts like
Boston, New York, Chicago,
New Orleans, Washington.
And cities especially
of interest to us
have some kind of
centralized assignment.
And that's something also
that the lab specializes
in studying-- how kids are
offered seats in districts
that have a lot of choice.
New York is really
the most interesting,
because first of all,
it's such a huge place,
and it has so many schools.
And they have a very
interesting choice system,
which mixes some element of
random assignment, actually.
Lotteries are involved in that.
But not only-- you also have
the screen schools that Clémence
talked about.
And you have the legendary
specialized high schools,
like Stuyvesant, Brooklyn
Tech, and Bronx Science.
We're very interested
in who gets
to go to these different schools
and what the consequences
of going to them are.
We also study a lot of the
most exciting and potentially
controversial education
policy reform projects.
We've looked extensively
for the past decade
at different sorts of charter
schools in different districts.
And we have a lot of
interesting results there.
I think one of our most exciting
set of findings in that domain
is the results for Chicago.
Where actually,
kids in Chicago--
so by way of background,
Chicago has a large exam school
sector--
schools that are competitive
and highly selective,
like Payton and North Side.
And what's kind of surprising
about those schools
is that they actually
seem to reduce
the achievement of
their applicants
when the applicant is offered
a seat in that sector.
And we puzzled over that.
Maybe exam schools
are not great.
Maybe there's a lot of selection
bias in terms of who actually
gets to go to the exam schools.
But why should they
reduce achievement?
And that turns out to have a
simple but maybe surprising
explanation.
A lot of the kids who apply
to Chicago's exam schools
have also applied to a
very successful charter
network called the Noble
Network of charter high schools.
And it's more impressive
to get into an exam school,
because that's selective.
Whereas Noble admits by lottery.
So kids who apply to
both Noble and charter--
tend to apply to
both Noble and exam,
tend to take an exam
offer when they get it.
And that means that the
likelihood that they
go to a charter is reduced.
And those charters are
very high performing,
and the kids would
have actually learned
more and been more
likely to go to college
if they had gone to
the charter school.
So that's a striking finding
and sure to be controversial
when we publish it.
The other dimension
of education reform
where we have some potentially
controversial findings
is research on vouchers.
Of course, Parag
knows this well,
because he's the leader
of the voucher team.
Parag and his coauthors have
studied a very interesting
voucher program in
Louisiana, where
kids who attend public schools
that are deemed by the state
to be low-performing
may get vouchers.
It's not guaranteed.
There's an element of
random assignment there too.
And we take advantage
of the random assignment
of the Louisiana voucher program
to estimate causal effects.
And it turns out, good hopes
and expectations for vouchers
notwithstanding, voucher
winners in Louisiana
tend to come out of that
program with lower test scores.
And I don't remember if you guys
looked at college in that study
as well-- just test scores?
Yeah, it's a short-run study.
Younger kids, and
it's a short-run.
But that is also
quite surprising.
Because the parents who
are applying for those
vouchers imagine that they're
getting a real opportunity
there.
But then, actually,
the causal effect
of going to a voucher school in
Louisiana seems to be negative.
So another reason I want to
tell these stories together--
the Chicago exam school
and the vouchers is--
I think it highlights
something I mentioned earlier.
Which is, in the lab, we don't
approach any of these questions
with any sort of
predisposition to find
that something is good or bad.
We're open to what the data say.
We're not pro-charter,
and we're not pro-exam,
and we're not pro-voucher.
We're not anti-voucher,
we're not anti-charter,
we're just studying
those things.
And we have a lot of
interesting findings.
And the results don't align
with any particular ideological
predispositions, I think.
I'll just briefly
mentioned that another part
of the work that the lab does
is related to higher education.
And we have a very large
ambitious and ongoing
randomized evaluation
of financial aid
in the post-secondary sector.
So these are kids in
Nebraska, who are applying
to Nebraska's public schools--
public universities
and colleges.
And there's a foundation there--
many will have heard the name--
the Buffett Foundation--
that pays for about 10%
of Nebraska's public college and
university students' tuition.
And we worked-- and
we are still working--
with the Buffett foundation in
a study that randomly allocates
some vouchers to some
kids so that we can find--
not vouchers, sorry-- some
post-secondary awards.
They're sort of like
vouchers, but it's just cash.
And but it can only be
used for public colleges
and universities.
And we're studying the
effects of higher education
financial aid on
educational attainment.
Do the kids who get that
sort of very generous--
and it is exceptionally
generous aid
that the Buffett
Foundation pays for.
They provide every dollar
of college-related costs.
There's an official number for
that the federal government
computes.
So they pay tuition,
they pay room and board,
they pay books, and
fees, and so on.
But there's still a
question as to what
the actual impact
of that money is,
because a lot of
the beneficiaries
might have been likely to
complete college anyway--
the money may not be
consequential for them.
So that's the kind of
question that we're
answering in that study.
And we have very
interesting findings there
which show that
overall, there is
an impact of financial aid
on post-secondary attainment.
But there are many kids who
are going to get these anyway,
and then there are groups where
the aid is super high impact.
And our findings suggest
that a more targeted program
would be likely to be much
more effective in terms
of increasing
post-secondary attainment.
Thank you, Josh.
And thanks, Clémence.
It's a common theme
of these studies
that designing more
effective policies
require studying the
consequences of existing
public policies.
And there is hope and
optimism that we can actually
make resources be
allocated more efficiently.
Let me turn now
to some questions
that we're getting from the
folks who've logged on today.
And there are a
couple of questions
that are quite related.
So let me try to combine them.
Kenneth Wise-- and Clémence,
maybe I'll come to you first
on this--
Kenneth Wise is asking
a question about,
is there a lower bound on
the degree of segregation,
say, in New York City.
And I think that's related
to another question
here about the role
of residential sorting
patterns in driving school
segregation patterns.
So a related question
is asking about
whether systems that have better
public transportation or better
busing would go further
to try to integrate cities
like New York.
So Clémence, I know you've
looked into that a little bit.
So maybe you could tell us.
Yeah, that's a great point.
And so, what I did in my study
is that I further decomposed
the figure I showed you.
So I looked at whether
I could explain
the residual segregation
in the system.
In particular, I
wanted to understand
what share of this
residual segregation
was due to just families
liking different schools,
and what share was
due to families
living in different places.
They all like the
same kind of schools,
but some people happen
to be much farther.
And so, they decided not
to send their kids there.
And what I find is, of the
residual segregation, 50%
is driven just by
residential sorting.
So which means, that
even if we imagine
a world in which everybody
likes the same school,
there will still be one
quarter of the segregation
we see today in New York
City just due to the fact
that people don't want to
commute hours to go to school.
So probably in these settings,
if public transportation
was better, you
could probably reduce
this residual segregation due
to residential segregation
even more.
But as of today, with the
current level of transportation
roughly a quarter of
the total segregation
is just due to the pattern
of residential sorting
in the city.
New York City--
a point on that--
New York City is quite peculiar,
because residential segregation
in New York City is strong.
But it's at a small
geographical scale.
Which means that in your
immediate surroundings,
people tend to be of your
same socioeconomic background
and race.
But if you go a mile
away already you
are going to another community.
So that makes it a city that is
relatively easier to integrate
than a city like
Chicago, for instance,
which is segregation in a much
larger scale than in New York
City.
Thank you, Clémence.
There's another question
also about your work
that I want to turn to next.
So Bob Mu has asked a
question about information
and involvement of
parents in these changes
to enrollment policies.
So New York City in
the Upper West Side
and in Northwest Brooklyn,
both of those areas
used an income quota.
And they had to set--
you said 25% in the Upper
West Side and more than 50%
in Northwest Brooklyn.
How did they arrive
at those numbers?
How did they communicate
those numbers to the public?
And is income the
right thing to target
in designing these policies,
or should something else
like your fallback option--
as you mentioned earlier--
or your race be a better proxy?
So for the first
part of the question,
I know I have more information
for the Brooklyn process.
But for in their case, the
process lasted two years.
And there was
several reports that
were made before they arrive
at the current policy.
There were a lot of group
work at the local level.
So that's how they decided
on the actual policy
they implemented.
They decided for
52%, because that's
the share of the free and
reduced price lunch students
in the district.
So this way, it's this
kind of arbitrary number
that is coming from
somewhere, like [INAUDIBLE]..
For Upper West Side, I
have less information.
I know that they also
had community meetings.
And so, there was discussion
with the stakeholders for sure.
For district 15, it
took a couple of years
to get to the policy.
So it was not an
immediate thing.
And the second question,
should the city
be targeting something else.
So it's not like--
you can't target by
race, because it's
forbidden by a Supreme
Court ruling from 2007.
So clearly, some cities
have decided to use proxies,
like income is relatively
good proxy for that.
But it's not something you
can legally do in any case.
Should you target
on other things.
I think it really depends on
what you're trying to achieve.
So if you're trying to achieve
a decrease in segregation,
probably income is
probably a good proxy.
If you're trying to
increase test score,
then you might be
interested in more
in looking what are
the option of students.
It is not always true that
lower-income students have
necessarily the worst options.
It can be the case.
But it's not
necessarily the case.
And so, that's where
we're going back
to the theme of trying to really
take the data as it is, and you
try to understand
New York City, which
are the option for
each kid, and how
you would design your policy in
the basis of this observation.
I know for Boston, that is
not the case, necessarily,
that the more income the
worst school of the city.
But it might be the
case in New York City.
I haven't really looked at that.
But that's an open
empirical question.
And in any case, it depends
on what are your aims.
What are you trying to achieve.
Are you trying to
achieve integration?
Are trying to achieve
higher test scores?
What is your aim
as a policymaker.
Terrific, Clémence.
We're getting close to near
the end of our time together.
So I want to wrap up
with two questions--
one for Clémence first
and then one for Josh.
So Clémence, I know all of us
in the Economics Department
and Blueprint Labs were so
thrilled when Josh was awarded
the Nobel Prize this year.
And I wonder if you could just
offer some comments on what
it's like working
with Josh, and what
it's like when your PhD
advisor wins a Nobel Prize.
Maybe I should sign off.
[LAUGHTER]
No, no.
I have a good story, actually.
So when I joined
MIT, we are assigned
to talk to people when
we go and visit this.
And actually, I had read Josh
books on [INAUDIBLE] in France.
And he was kind of God for me.
And so, I was like, I don't want
to meet with him, because I'm
way too scared to look stupid.
And I think that
something I've learned
a lot during these years,
is that you can't look
too stupid in front of Josh.
It's OK to say stupid things.
And so, I think it's
something I really
enjoyed working with Josh
is that I learned a lot.
And I felt like it was OK
not to be always right.
And actually, that's
how you learn.
Really, you can't
be always right.
And I find that's a
very enriching part
of this opportunity
of working with Josh
is to learn from the best.
And even have these kind of very
collegial spirit, in which you
are not like-- you don't
fear saying something stupid
anymore.
So I'm very grateful
of the opportunity.
That's very nice, Clémence.
Yeah.
There's an old saying,
if we weren't confused,
it wouldn't be called
research, right?
[LAUGHTER]
Exactly.
No stupid question.
[LAUGHTER]
Josh, let me have you answer
the last question today.
So I know you're about to
actually receive the Nobel
Prize in a couple of days.
And unfortunately, you're
not able to go to Stockholm
because of COVID concerns.
But maybe sometime
in the near future.
When you look back and
reflect on all the excitement
of the past year, I wonder if
you had any parting thoughts
for the next generation--
people like Clémence and other
scholars that are burgeoning--
starting their research
careers-- on how to proceed
with your research life and any
other tips that you
want to pass on.
Sure, Parag.
Yeah.
We're getting our medals
in Washington on Monday.
Unfortunately, can't go to
Stockholm and meet the King.
But hopefully, the King
will wait for us next year.
But in some ways, the Nobel
is kind of a distraction.
I love my work.
And I hope to be
able to get back
to it after all this ceremonial
stuff is taken care of.
Of course, I'm
flattered and honored.
But I'm lucky to have
a job that I love.
And I think that's
what our students are
headed for-- our
graduate students there.
I hope they'll join me
in loving their work.
And it's not that every
minute is a good time.
But we have a lot of
intellectual challenge.
And one of the wonderful
things about our lab is also,
it's not just thinking about
things and proving theorems.
We're very engaged
in the real world.
We interact with lots of school
districts, and educators,
and people who are involved
in education policy.
And that's very enriching.
And it helps us keep our eye
on the ball-- that there's
actual children out
there in school,
and that educational
policy affects
their lives and their futures.
So we're just very lucky.
We get to do something
that really affects
a lot of people's lives.
And it's super interesting
and challenging work.
I can't think of a better job.
Great, Josh.
I can see the passion
oozing out as you talk.
So I think we're just at time.
So I wanted to thank everyone--
Clémence, Josh, the folks
from the Open Learning Office,
the folks at MITili
and MIT more generally.
Thank you all for joining
in and participating
and for your questions.
And that's a wrap.
Thanks, everyone.